ابرز التطورات هو هي استمرار للقصف
الاسرائيلي من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
وغارات متفرقه ما بين الفينه والاخرى
اللافت في هذا اليوم وفي صباح هذا اليوم
وربما من بعد منتصف الليل الغارات باتت
مكثفه على منطقه شمال قطع غزه لا سما
جباليا وكذلك في مدينه غزه خلال الايام
الماضيه ربما انخفضت حده الغارات
الاسرائيليه على تلك المناطق بعد ما انسحب
الجيش الاسرائيلي من اغلب هذه المخ ممات
وهذه الاحياء في مدينه غزه وفي شمال قطاع
غزه وانخفضت حده الغارات لكنها باتت ربما
مركزه بشكل اكبر على المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه لكن بالامس كان هناك قصف مدفعي
وصباح هذا اليوم وايضا استمرت الغارات ما
بين فينه واخرى هناك غارات اسرائيليه على
منازل مدنيه في شمال القطاع ك كذلك في
مدينه غزه وعندما نتحدث عن هذا هذه
الاماكن شمال القطاع ومدينه غزه نحن نتحدث
عن احياء ب كاملها دمرت سويت بالارض
وبالتالي المباني القائمه هي عددها قليل
جدا وبالتالي تكون مكتظه عن بكره ابيها
بالاضافه الى مراكز النزوح الغير مهيئه
والتي لا ترعاها اي مؤسسه دوليه وبالتالي
الغارات الاسرائيليه على هذه المنازل توقع
عشرات من الشهداء والجارحى الغارات ايضا
باتت مكثفه على مناطق وسط القطاع لا سما
مخيمي المغازي والبريج وهذان المخيمين هما
ربما اللذان يتعرضان الى القصف الاعنف الى
القصف الاكثر كث لا سما المناطق والاحياء
الشرقيه من هذان المخيمين مخيم المغازي
تعرض لغارات عنيفه كذلك مخيم البريج القصف
المدفعي مازال مستمرا هناك تحليق ايضا
لطائرات كواد كابتر اسرائيليه في تلك
المناطق تطلق النار على كل من يحاول
التحرك طواقم الاسعاف طواقم الدفاع المدني
لا ممنوعه من الدخول الى تلك المناطق هذه
الطواقم تعمل على تمشيط المناطق التي
تتعرض الى قصف اسرائيلي في كل صباح لكن هي
ممنوعه الان من هذه من عمليات التمشيط
بفعل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي بفعل
استمرار اطلاق النار من قبل هذه المسيرات
الاسرائيليه على على المواطنين وعلى ايضا
سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع المدني
وايضا الاخطر من كل ذلك استمرار انقطاع
الاتصالات والانترنت لليوم الخامس على
التوالي وهذا يعني ان المواطنين غير
قادرين على الوصول الى طواقم الدفاع
المدني وطواقم الاسعاف ولا الاتصال بهم
وبالتالي من يصاب من يستشهد في الاماكن
الخطيره لا يستطيع الوصول الى المست
مستشفيات ومن يستطيع الوصول الى المستشفى
الاسعافات بحاجه الى وقت طويل من اجل
العوده هو يبلغهم يصل الى المستشفى عبر
سياره او عبر عربه تجرها الحيوانات يبلغ
المستشفى ومن ثم تتحرك سيارات الاسعاف
وطواقم الدفاع المدني الى تلك المناطق
بالتاكيد هذا ياخذ وقتا كبيرا ويودي بحياه
ايضا العشرات من المصابين من جراء
الاستمرار من جراء استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي ايضا المناطق الشرقيه والمناطق
الشماليه في مخيم النصيرات ما بين شارع
العشرين وشارع صلاح الدين هذه المناطق
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف ايضا شنت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه احزمه ناريه على تلك
المناطق ما بين مخيم واحد في مخيم
النصيرات وكذلك ما بين شارع العشرين هذه
المناطق تعرضت الى غارات عنيفه ولم يعرف
بعد طبيعه الاهداف التي استهدفتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وقصفت بسبب
ايضا انقطاع الاتصالات وكذلك بسبب منع
سيارات الدفاع المدني وسيارات الاسعاف من
الوصول الى تلك المناطق كذلك المناطق
الشماليه لمخيم النصيرات تتعرض الى قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وايضا في كل المناطق
التي يمنع وصول سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات
الدفاع المدني اليها هناك عشرات من
الشهداء ما زالوا ملقون على الارض بالامس
فقط تمكنت سيارات الاسعاف من الوصول الى
اطراف عبسان الى اطراف مخيم المغازي
وانتشلت عددا من الجثامين الذين ظلوا
ملقون على الارض من جراء عمليه الاستهداف
المباشره ايضا منطقه خانيونس منطقه لا سما
المناطق الشرقيه الجنوبيه لخان يونس منطقه
جورت اللوت منطقه وسط البلد منطقه البطن
السمين هذه المناطق تتعرض في كل يوم وفي
كل لحظه وفي كل حين الى قصف اسرائيلي يسمع
صدى الانفجارات الناجمه عن القصف
الاسرائيلي هنا في اقصى الجنوب في رفح
والقصف ما زال مستمر ومتواصل ايضا يسمع
اصوات اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين عناصر
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
مستمره ومتواصله وبالتاكيد
عند تمكن سيارات الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع
المدني من التوجه الى تلك المناطق فهذا
يعني ان هناك انتشال لاعداد من الشهداء من
تلك المناطق منطقه رفح كذلك تعرضت الى قصف
قبل منتصف الليل والغارات في رفح لها
خصوصيه فهذا يعني ان
الغارات موجهه الى المنطقه الاكثر اكتظاظا
بالسكان الى المنطقه المزدحمه الى المنطقه
التي يطلب الجيش الاسرائيلي من سكان
القطاع ال وهذه المنطقه منطقه مراج التي
قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي فيها ربما هي
المناطق الاكثر اكتضاض في رفح وبالتالي
كان هناك عدد من الشهداء والجرحى شكرا
جزيلا لك هشام زقوط مراسل الجزيره كنت
معنا من رفح في جنوبيه قطاع غزه